we have three plus blank is equal to ten
so pause the video and try to figure out
what the blank is what do i have to add
to three to get to ten
so you've had a go at it now let's see
if we can do this together
so over here i have three of these
these i guess you could say purple
these purple pinkish circles
and i have ten boxes one two three four
5 6 7 8 9 10.
so one way to think about it is how many
more circles do i need to add to fill up
all of the boxes well let's just count
that together i need to add
1 2
7 to fill up all 10 boxes
so 3 plus what is equal to 10 well 3
plus 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
is equal to ten let's do one more of
these
so now
i have
six plus blank
is equal to ten
so again try to pause the video and see
if you can figure out what the blank is
what do i need to add to 6 to get to 10.
let's do it together so
we now have 1 2 3 4 5 6 circles
we have ten boxes here one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten so we
just have to think about how many more
circles do we need to fill up all the
boxes to get to ten because we already
have six filled in
well we need one two three
four to get to ten so let's just fill
that in
six plus
four
is equal to ten or we could say even
that four plus six is equal to ten
either way